this is a production of Cornell
University of Cornell University
our daughter is in veterinary school
[Laughter]
supporting Cornell now for almost seven
years thank you very much for inviting
us here it's a pleasure to come back
come back to this room because I
remember clearly coming seminars myself
as a student here and it's a very
interesting to come back a number of
years later and talk about what we have
accomplished and what we are doing and
what our our plans are going to be
because we are far from done we are
definitely in a growth phase on our farm
in a generational succession on our farm
our son is taking over a great deal of
it and our younger son is taking much
more leadership at the feed mill so we
have a lot of plans of things that are
changing and coming up in both of our
businesses and it's it's exciting it's
exciting to be on the cutting edge it's
but it's also exciting to have been in
organic farming in upstate New York for
the past 25 30 years and seeing the
changes because it is truly inspiring to
see this many people at Cornell truly
involved engaged in organic farming
research and interested in organic
farming production in it's a lot of fun
when we speak in the Midwest because
farmers are envious of our State
University being Cornell Cornell has
taken us further ahead in organic than I
think I'm biased but I also think I'm
correct has actually helped us jump
ahead much further and made more
scientific progress in understanding the
how and why of organic farming along
with soil health of any school there is
and what's especially fun is to have in
Iowa and have Iowa State Alumni
unwellness come up and tell me that they
envy us for being here
a little background on our operation we
do farm 1,600 acres of certified organic
grain crops we farm a lot of different
crops and we'll get to that in a few
minutes we'll show you a whole list of
everything that we grow which is pretty
impressive
we've been farming organically certified
organic since 1992 so we have been close
as a farmer from way back he grew up on
a farm he was a dairy farmer when we got
married we were looking for ways to make
the farm more profitable and organic
seemed to be a nice niche that would be
something that we could make a little
extra money in it it was very appealing
to our perspective our philosophy and so
it was a very easy thing for us to
decide to go into in the early 90s
before there were really good markets
for organic green crops but it was it
was something that we felt strongly
would grow and it did first few farm
farmers in this area who were farm and
grain organically didn't have good
markets but by the time we reached a
critical mass of quantity and quality
suddenly the buyers became in here
and our markets definitely grew the
first really big benefit we saw from
organic farming was the markets we knew
from our observation our experience in
our financial records that when we had a
diverse system on our farm a wide row
wide variety of crops in rotation that
our crops were more profitable had less
problems required less inputs the big
problem with that was that in the
conventional market some of our rotation
crops were only marginally more
profitable to grow than to take to the
elevator than they were to just mow em
down in trash them because there was
just no demand when we got into the
organic certified organic market we
started having buyers calling us asking
for things that we did not have markets
for before so there's a real important
concept that we found with biodiversity
that if you don't have the market you're
not going to have the diversity on your
farm
so certified organic Mars organic under
NOP rules of tremendous marketing tool
because it opens those doors and allows
us to have more flexibility as to what
we grow in 1996 the first organic dairy
farmers came to in upstate New York came
to us and said now you've got grain and
we know somebody else who has a mixer
grinder and a blower truck could you
start making feed for us and there were
maybe three maybe four farms at that
point no big deal
we thought we could probably do this and
we did but by 2001 we had over a hundred
customers and we were seriously pressing
at the boundaries of what we could do on
our farm at the same point AG way the
big cooperative in the Northeast was
going bankrupt and selling off all their
property and they came to us and said
we've got this feed mill here in pinyon
and we get rid of it would you like to
buy it and we bought it and that point
it had then really run into the ground
if anything had broken if anything it's
filled if anything had gotten this
placed over the past 10-15 years people
just walked away from it it was a mess
we hired one of our local and a knight
young men to help us clean it up and we
cleaned and cleaned and clean and try to
figure out where all the switches went
to and what which wires were still good
in which were not and it took us six
months but within six months we were
able to start grinding certified organic
feed at that point we thought we could
hire Daniel the Mennonite kid part-time
and maybe just do a little bit of feed
now and then but within a couple of
years we realized that was not
reasonable and we started hiring more
employees now we have 12 employees we've
got two trucks on the road full-time and
we are grinding and shipping more feed
out of Lakeview and AG we ever did even
in their heyday and it is entirely
certified organic feed it is a lot of
it's dairy it goes all over upstate New
York and northern pencil
but increasingly we've got a market for
at the backyard folks the backyard
chicken folks the backyard
small animal Pig sheep and goat and also
seed so we ship pallets all over the
Northeast by common carrier and it's
it's gotten to be quite a business a lot
bigger a lot bigger than we expected it
to get to be and it's been an
interesting kind of wild ride but what
the neat thing is is that we it's it
it's all certified organic grain and we
buy as much as possible from local
farmers this has allowed us to provide a
market for a diversity of different
certified organic green crops from
farmers especially in a 50 to 75 mile
radius around pinion it gives these
farmers a reliable well paid market we
take their crops out of the field at
harvest we dry their corn and their
other grains we store it we give them a
sense of security of reliability of
decency we were talking on the way down
about how how sadly frequently farmers
are dealt with dishonestly by their
buyers and their suppliers and we're
seeing so much evidence of right that
right now with the farm crisis being
accelerating we've gotten a call on the
way down from someone in Pennsylvania
that class is going to be speaking down
there next week and the the financial
crisis and the sense of panic is just
reaching massive proportions because the
Amish farms down there or losing their
milk markets and they have no idea what
to do and they feel very much like
they're being taken taken advantage of
that they're being lied to that they're
being mistreated well from the very
start we committed that Lakeview would
not do that
that we would treat our farmers honestly
reliably we would be there as a partner
and we would provide good quality feed
we provide a good quality market be the
pivot that the organic community could
count on to be honest and to be fair and
to be high quality
an overriding principle that we have
discovered over the last 30 years is
that when we have an agronomic problem
that seems to defy solving and this
could include problems that even the
best pesticides and things that are not
allowed for organic farmers don't deal
with we have discovered that we can
generally solve those problems by
introducing the right new kind of
biodiversity species by adjusting the
biodiversity and that has really turned
our farm around by having the discipline
of not being able to use the quick fixes
and the band-aids and the reactive
approaches we've had to look upstream
we've had to learn that what we see in
our fields is due to what we've done
there in the past we have to look back
and see what is the history and start
seeing what we're looking at and taking
the clues that nature gives us we for
instance and this is in the field of
soil health found that when growing dry
beans if we introduce yellow mustard or
buckwheat it almost completely
eliminates the root rot pathogens when
we started growing dry beans on our farm
we thought it was like we found a way to
print our own money it was such a
profitable crop but by the second and
third time we've grown the dry beans in
the same field our yields had dropped in
less than half
that's where Cornell came to the rescue
and I can't overstate what a big
difference it is made to be able to go
to our extension specialists and our
researchers here in Ithaca with a
problem and have them actually look at
it and explain what's happening and help
us desire design a plan how do we change
the system so that we can deal with the
problem incidentally after learning
about the dry beam problem and Georgia
Bowie was interest Romero in that and
this goes right to the soil health team
solving a lot of other problems our dry
bean yields actually doubled again and
went higher than they had been before
and that this is the importance of
having a university and I know I'm
preaching to the choir here but if we
don't put the public funding back in
public research we're going to really
miss the boat because part of what
brought put this country on the map is
that we had a commitment and enough
money to fund this kind of research that
doesn't bring back immediate returns but
that produce much bigger returns
downstream in the loan in the long run
companies have have a responsibility to
make money if it's really hard for them
to spend money researching things where
there's not an immediate payback yet
when you look at the kind of research
that's been done here and then look at
how that is stimulated business and
stimulated things that were not possible
before we see that it's a tremendous
payback for the taxpayer dollar we love
technology we're very much into it and
we'll talk to you more about this in a
few minutes what's what's what's about
to arrive at our farm which is really
interesting but this is not something
new we decided about 10 years ago to
start putting solar panels on every
available surface on our farm at this
point all of the stationary energy the
non mobile energy on our farm that we
use is generated by solar we also have
three electric cars and so most of our
running around it's
amazing how infrequently a farmer
actually needs a pickup truck most of
the running around from field to field
and to go get parts and to do a lot of
the the general driving on a farm
doesn't need to be in a pickup truck it
can be in a needy car and run off solar
so which we're trying very hard to
reduce our energy use as much as we
absolutely can we've also brought in a
good deal of European equipment for
tillage that does less damage to the
soil that is more precise and camera and
GPS guided for cultivation so that it's
each pass that we make in the field does
the maximum amount of good with the
least amount of soil damage or soil
disruption and what's coming hopefully
tomorrow are the start of six containers
of custom-built
seed cleaning equipment from China we've
been working class and and our son Peter
had been working with Chinese engineers
since last summer to design a system of
optical sorters and all sorts of other
accessory equipment it is it is a it is
a project of a proportion that we have
never conceived of before we had to put
up to a whole new buildings and it's
it's really it's really something else
but it's it's where we're going with
agriculture we have to have the capacity
the infrastructure in order to be able
to produce grain in accordance in
compliance with disma the food
modernisation Safety Act if we're gonna
get into more the food quality grains we
need to be able to do a better quality
job of cleaning seed we need to be able
to handle and store grain in the most
modern way possible and we need to do
this not just for us but for others in
the neighborhoods so that we can provide
markets for them one special appeal I'll
make to our university is in GPS not
just the field mapping but in helping
farmers
troubleshoot helping farmers evaluate
how it'll fit on their farms I think
here's a role that extension could
really make a difference in we've got a
model of selling machinery in this
country that is appropriate for the
1900s but it's not appropriate for today
and that's to sell as much iron as you
can and be busy selling the third piece
while your first customer is struggling
to make what you sold and work we really
need independent advisors who helped
farmers select what they're going to do
to be sure that it pays back and GPS for
us as an example it's a cute quip but
it's true don't ask me to correct this
problem I just found a fourth or correct
this mistake I just spent a fortune
making it I did that with our GPS and it
took a son who had been in Europe and
was able to tell Dad hey you screwed up
just admit it to figure this out it
tends to human nature is to double down
on these mistakes and not admit it but
worm my mistake was I thought that GPS
because of its accuracy could control
cultivation and I'm still convinced it
could but the truth is there are better
ways to do it just because you can do
something in a certain way doesn't mean
we should stop looking at how else could
we do it and this the next level is
camera guidance and this is where
technology is taking us forward in
quantum leaps now the the first camera
guidance that worked and worked well was
looking for contrast where they mounted
the camera known distance above the
ground and it looked for parallel lines
the right distance apart which it could
identify as rose and when it worked well
it was more accurate than a human being
in fact when they didn't work when I
wasn't quite as accurate as we wanted to
be the manufacturer told me something
that's counterintuitive he said speed up
you get more data points and you'd be
more accurate
no people I just can't do something that
fast and the resolution of these cameras
allows them to see the crop when it's so
small that at my age oh and I need
glasses I probably can't see as good as
the camera can but that's only the
beginning
now just because this thing works
perfectly when we're trying it out in
the test doesn't mean that we can turn
an untrained employee on it and have it
work day in and day out and this is
where we need to continue to make
advances what we learned I just give a
give this example is that when the Sun
was at a right angle to the cultivator
and you were going in one direction you
were fine when you turned it around it
would go crazy because you had the
shadow
on the machine plus the strobe effect of
the cleats on the tires turning which
really confused it our son just solved
this working with the company by putting
a camera on both sides it was about a
two hundred dollar modification plus it
took a little software code but the
salesman didn't tell us that this this
is where we really need to have the
university get out in front again about
five years ago we were asked to come
down and give a seminar to the Alliance
for science folks here at Cornell to
organic farmers I think they expected us
to Waddle in in Frankenfish outfits we
didn't we asked a series of questions
and and one of them was and and and I'm
not pointing fingers whatsoever but
those of us in agriculture needs to
think about where we draw the circle
around what constitutes success if you
go to the local coffee shop in any rural
farming community and all the farmers
are bellying up there to their coffee
cups you know you're gonna hear 200
bushel corn 200 225 you're gonna hear
that in that alone you might hear some
dairy farmers talking about their their
milk yield but that's about all you're
gonna hear you're gonna hear that
success is quantity and it is measurable
in bushels or gallons or hundredweight
but you're not going to talk about any
of you're not gonna hear anything about
any of the consequences unintended or
intended for that kind of yield 200
bushel corn that's pretty impressive
need a whole lot of corn sweetener and
processed corn and a whole lot of
different things plus 40 percent of that
goes into ethanol by law but what it
does not talk about are all the
concurrent consequences that come with
that 200 bushel corn the environmental
consequences the social consequences the
long-term resilience
quinces they're a lot of different
things that are part and parcel to that
200 bushel corn and if we're going to be
honest about what we're doing and where
we're going from here we have to see
that the circle has to go around the
whole thing it has to encompass water it
has to encompass and we've just come
back from Colorado we have heard about
water issues in the West with irrigation
water are profound the farmers in the
San Luis Valley of Colorado are being
told they have to recharge their aquifer
by 2031 and they have not a clue how
they're going to do that
but they've also been told that if they
don't recharge it they're going to have
their wells turned off literally and
that can happen farmers are a minority
the public is demanding some changes and
the public has more votes but to be
honest you know we're picking on
conventional AG we need to draw that
same circle around our organic system
and we sometimes we're not happy with
some of the things that were in that
circle and one thing that I like to
point out to our fellow organic farmers
at meetings is that organic soybeans are
the organic farmers dirty secret
because soybeans produce very little
organic matter we don't always get cover
crops on them in the fall so they leave
the soil exposed to erosion you know and
it's a lot of fun to blame the Corn Belt
farmers for losing 2 pounds of soil for
every pound of corn they grow but maybe
we should turn the finger the other way
and see ask how many pounds of soil our
organic farmers losing and I think
soybeans is where we fall flat and this
is a place where there's some really
exciting work being done now also energy
and that's why we were looking at solar
on our farm you know there there are
weaknesses in every system and I think
no matter how good a system is there is
room to make it better and so if you
talk to anyone government they're gonna
define risk management as far as the
insurance policies and programs that you
can buy for Ag insurance for us risk
management means something entirely
different risk management is our risk
management is is predicated and grounded
in diversity and flexibility the only
way we're going to adjust to changing
conditions the change in climate
changing availability of different
inputs and also in different markets is
to be as diverse as we can be
we have learned as Klaus said that
diversity is the key to our being able
to handle diseases insects and other
issues it's also the key to our being
able to handle changes in who's buying
what you know what are available markets
are what our price is whether or not
we're going to be profitable the more
different crops we're growing the more
diversity we have the better off we're
going to be another challenge I'd like
to give our university is that we need
to do more systems research and one of
we go turn the clock way back and I love
saying his name because Americans can't
pronounce it but goeth the German
playwright criticized the modern
agricultural research that was being
done in Germany
quote-unquote in the 1800's by saying
that it was changing one variable and
measuring one effect while missing an
almost infinite potential number of
effects that that variable was having
and we got very good that's not a
criticism of the scientific method as it
was applied but we got so good at doing
that that we tended to miss some of the
other effects that we're having and I
think in measuring yield which was no
question very important we were missing
the question as are we affecting the
future ability of that soil to produce
crops by producing that crop now in the
way that we are of course that is going
to come back to soil health pretty soon
and that's a wonderful leading because
as we have been working in in in organic
farming for the past thirty years
there's been something concurrent going
on in American agriculture and now
suddenly everybody absolutely everybody
is talking about soil health and it's
just kind of a funny thing because we
were talking about it 30 years ago but
now you can't pick up a farm paper for a
magazine you can't pick up anything to
do with agriculture without seeing
articles about soil health which is good
we're not all talking about the same
thing that isn't necessarily good but at
least we're talking and at least we're
recognizing that a major limitation in
our resilience and in our productivity
is the quality the health of the soil
and there are a lot of reasons for this
here are eight you know a healthy soil
will hold more water in a way in a dry
year and drain better you know in a wet
year it'll resist erosion it will
provide more internally cycling
nutrients so not as many will need to be
purchased so that saves some money it
will be resistant to compaction it will
increase infiltration I mean there's
just there's so many good reasons to pay
attention to the soil now how we do that
and what it means is the question for
those of you who have taken soil science
with in the past you know years
[Laughter]
you remember that soil is made up of
three major components
physical chemical and biological the
physical part of it is the the parent
material that's that's what you get when
you buy a piece of land the chemical is
what you can amend more or less it's
partly what you get with your parent
material and then what you can buy and
put on and the biological is what lives
there and these are the microbes this is
food web these are the earthworms and
all the other critters that are eating
each other and eating organic matter and
living on the roots and some of them are
pathogens most of them are not and it is
the diversity of life that is under our
feet that we do not know anything we
don't we do not see you know some people
know a whole lot about it but most of us
don't see it and therefore we don't
think about it and I was teaching a
class at the Community College years ago
in biology and I started talking about
this and showing some really bizarre
pictures of soil organisms and one of
the students came up to me with this
starry eyes just stunned and she said I
didn't know how much I didn't know and I
think this is really important that we
don't know how much we don't know
there's more diversity in a handful of
soil life or the life in the soil then
there is above-ground
you know we there we don't most of the
species in the soil have never been
described we don't know what they're
doing there we don't know how they're
relating to each other we don't know
what's important we don't know how if we
do this you know tillage or pesticides
it's having an effect on this but what
we are coming to the conclusion about is
yes the physical the chemical are
important but the greatest of these is
the biological our ability to have a
healthy soil is the microbial life of
the soil and therefore we need to treat
it as if it is important we have a
friend up in Canada who's a grazing
specialist a dairy grazing specialist
she doesn't believe it a farm can have a
healthy be healthy without cows and we
tell her that
we agree we have cows too but we have a
lot of other livestock
we tend them very carefully we take good
care of them they're just really really
small and I think it's very important to
think of the life in our soil as if they
were our livestock because they are that
important well until recently we knew
much more about what was out on the the
Stars or the moon than we did about what
was underground and that may be
overstating it a little but not by much
but my personal opinion is one of the
tragedies of the past 20 years has been
the war between organic farmers and
biotechnology here are two natural
allies we need the tools that
biotechnology brings us to understand
what's in the soil
we can't even look at some of these
organisms without killing them they
would go forward
um this picture was taken actually this
is an interesting shot it was taken in
the 40s we're guessing the scientist was
of one of the worst Nazis in the
Austrian education system
his widow actually published the work
many years later and what they did they
used stains and they used the tools that
are available the time to try to look at
soil at this level and they made some
really interesting advances which for me
are mind-boggling that with the crude
tools they had and the limited capacity
they had for doing research but they
were able to see as much as they were
using stains this professor is nameless
Akira was able to see that most of the
soil life was an aquatic ecosystem you
know we think of it being terrestrial
but when you get down to the microbial
level most things live in that water
film that occupies the surface area in
soil on earth and there is in all of the
freshwater bodies of water combined and
when we look at climate change
regulating water and storing carbon look
at the organism that does it the soil is
kind of a super organism I'm going to
digress just a little bit and throw out
another challenge to our researchers
when we talk about soil health it's
tempting to think that this is a 1 to
100 scale
that you know you can just great make
the soil healthier and healthier I think
that's a we're missing the boat
the reason I do is the most healthy
environment
for corn is not going to be the most
healthy environment for rice grows are
extreme examples but our goal really in
soil health aside from water regulation
storing carbon you know maintaining a
balanced ecosystem is that when we're
growing a crop we would like it to be
the best adapted species for the
conditions that exist in that soil we
have to recognize that every plant that
grows is essentially farming a group of
microbes in the ground and I've heard a
really great talk and I don't want to
embarrass dr. Venice but you made a very
brilliant did a reported on a very
brilliant piece of work where you took
soil health data and we're able to
predict which crops were going to do
best and I really think that's a
direction that offers breakthroughs if
we could take a soil health test and
from that task prescribe what kind of
what cover crops to grow what crop is
likely to do best and in real time just
like we do with chemical fertilizers be
able to say do this now and in so many
months you're going to have this field
ready to do something or you've got a
disease problem this is the route you
have to take to balance the biology so
that that organism is not pathogenic
that has enormous possibilities and this
world is just opening up I was asked to
be on an advisory board for a Silicon
Valley company called trace genomics and
I remember Janet he's doing work on this
with much cruder tools 30 years ago but
now they can take a soil sample and put
it in this analyzer and sequence the
entire genome of all the organisms in
that soil and an interesting observation
they've made with that technology
they're saying whether or not the
pathogens are present is not a good
indicator of whether you're going to
have pathogenicity it has to do with who
else is there there's a lot we don't
know and there's a lot we can't as
ordinary farmers be able to tell
we count on their researchers to help us
with this but one of the things we can
do is take a handful of soil squeeze it
and then relax and let it and see how it
falls if it falls with crumbs and and
looks looks healthy and looks loose that
means it has stable aggregates and
that's a pretty good indication of a
healthy microbial population it's not
exact but it's something we can do on
our farm if we squeeze it and we let
loose and it looks pasty and it sticks
together and it looks kind of kind of
compacted then we should be looking at
doing different techniques we need to be
giving our Meg microbes more to eat and
a different perhaps a different approach
to killing and before we get into other
topics actually this is not where it's
supposed to be
well good we'll come back to that I'm
sorry there but but in to improve soil
health some general principles is to
improve the soil physical condition the
drainage in New York most places need
additional drainage and we've put in
miles and miles and miles of tile drains
and diversion ditches and other ways of
reducing erosion and improving internal
in our soil getting more hiking or
cycling high quality organic matter in
the soil will give our microbes
something to eat and so cover cropping
leaving residue not scalping the fields
of every last bit of green this is going
to feed our microbes and then we correct
the nutrients and then we buy the
products too many people have gone out
and put a lot of money into what is
commonly known as a bug in a joke there
are a lot of products out there many of
which are organically approved that have
all sorts of fun micro microorganisms in
them in a nice nice gallon and you mix
them into your sprayer and spray them on
and life's good the trouble is if if you
build it they will come if you don't
build it they will die and I think it's
very important that all of us realized
that just buying a solution in a jug
does not solve the problems I'm looking
for the first salesman who comes along
selling a bug and a jug who tells me to
leave a control stir and therein is this
intersection of biotechnology and
organic farming I believe we're not far
from where we can take a genomic look at
the soil and predict fairly accurately
if some of these microbes are going to
be of benefit or even if they're likely
to take hold and do anything because if
they're already there it won't pay to
put them on or if the conditions are
hostile to them it probably won't pay
either you know this this is a way that
we can start fine-tuning our inputs in a
way that there are a lot more effective
a lot more cost-effective and it's
another place where the university is
has the potential to add tremendous
value to agriculture the good thing
about organics is that there are markets
for lots of different crops and they're
good profitable markets their markets
that are reliable what we have tried to
help the farmers that we work was do is
to develop a repertoire
get some ideas of what different windows
of opportunity throughout a 12-month
period what they could be planting what
they could be harvesting what they could
be plugging a short-term cover crop in
if they've got six weeks of bare ground
how they can be using their soil more
wisely to both produce more profitable
crops but also produce in the off times
crops that will help enhance the quality
of their soil and feed their microbes we
don't tell them what you know this is
our crop rotation therefore this works
try to do it we don't want people to use
ours as a template but what's more
important is to build their own
repertoire and then choose from it when
they have windows of opportunity the fun
thing is back to years ago and in in at
the end of the season in November I say
it close and Peter down at the kitchen
table and I said ok what did we grow
this year and we started listing it off
and we listed off corn well we grew corn
for food because we have some open
pollinated corn and we grew some for
distilling because we had a small market
for that most of it went for feed but we
did grow for some for seed because we
were working with Margaret Smith at the
time on hybrid production and and so we
listed all the different crops and all
the different uses and it just kept
going and going and going down to the
end we sort of switched over to the
things we raised for our own use because
we try to be as self-sufficient on our
farm as possible and eat as much of our
own food as we can but this is our risk
management this diversity of a crop and
market is why we we can roll with what
comes because if one things down
something else will be up like to share
a fun observation that's we started
growing rye as a winter cover and then
we discovered it did a little better if
we put some tillage radish in with it in
fact we found our wheat yields went up
if we put just a pound or so of tillage
radish seed in in the fall
but then why wouldn't the cover crop do
better so we through the tillage radish
in the Rye we also put the Austrian
winter peas in the Rye which produce
nitrogen for it and the Austrian winter
pea shoots are in the spring so you can
have your cover crop and eat it too and
have you ever had the frustration of
growing radishes in the spring and they
get these bugs in them and there's so
much work and they have weeds in them
and I walked around trying to kick
myself we didn't when we threw those
tillage radishes in in the fall into
that mix there were no weeds there were
no bugs
there was no weeding labor we could just
go out and catch and pick our vegetables
in fact there is a market for this and
in the spring the Austrian winter peas
are the first high-value green salad
crop that you can get again we're
getting all the benefits of the cover
crop and we're also growing vegetables
in a way that requires virtually no
labor so it's interesting how we can
learn things are there's always a better
way to do something no matter how good
we think we are at what we're doing and
and and some real energetic intense
young people from Stone Barns Research
Center down in the Hudson Valley come up
every fall to harvest not just our
tillage radishes but why shoot and then
take it back and turn it into all sorts
of delicious things at the restaurant
it's it's we have so much fun it's
amazing what people are willing to come
out and pay for a salad made out of rye
I thought it was pretty good but when
you pay that much it tastes better we
learn and from this we learn something
that's even more important oh we're
getting really variable climate we've
got much wider swings than we used to
have and in a recent
bitter cold spell that killed almost
everything we discovered that where we
had the mixture of the tillage radish
the Austrian winter pea and the Rye and
I think we're going to be throwing kale
into that mix in the near future and
turnips but the the rive formed almost
like a ream a and none of the tillage
radishes were harmed so where the
tillage radishes were growing
unprotected they were done and yet where
they were in the mixture they survived
and continued to produce biomass and
protect the soil and grow for about
another five or six weeks afterwards so
these mixtures have tremendous benefit
another thing we noticed was that when
you grow the Austrian winter peas by
themselves they're subject to winter
damage and it's easy to miss construe
this as saying they can't tolerate cold
but when they're mixed with a small
grain again that gives cover and keeps
the wind off we discovered that their
damage is really desiccation not
absolute cold and when they have the
protection of the small grain the winter
peas survive fine even at ten below zero
it has more to do with this desiccation
effect so this is this is all seeing
what we're looking at and being open to
learning new things it's amazing how
much fun we can have just growing cover
crops most of the professor's here in
this room have done research on our farm
students may not know that and we try to
use our offer our farm up as a living
lab of an actual organic farm where
authentic research can be done under
organic conditions one of the research
projects were in now right now is with
Matt Ryan and it is on organic Noto we
have done a lot of research on this and
a lot more is yet to come but trying to
come up with ways to reduce tillage to
reduce soil disturbance and still get
weed control which is a challenge in
organics without being able to cultivate
and get good quality crops which
can be a real challenge if we don't have
a good we control so there were a lot of
factors that need to be covered in order
to have this actually be effective we've
been working with folks at Rodale to
come up with equipment and then
fine-tuning that because southern
Pennsylvania is not upstate New York and
some of the timing is different for what
worked in Pennsylvania and what works in
upstate New York here's a little movie
and this shows something kind of neat if
you just wait here comes the roller the
roller is rolling down a combination of
rye and Austrian winter piece this is in
May right okay winter peas are about
seven feet tall
they grow upright a lot better when they
have something to climb on and being
crimped and the stems are broken but now
just wait for it behind the tractor is
the grain drill the soybeans are being
planted so in one pass we are rolling
down the Rye crimping it making sure
that it stays down and then we are
planting the soybeans this is one of the
ways we've done this last year we
actually mowed off some of the tradition
of the Rye in the triticale and planted
into undisturbed soil but it had been
mowed off this we we were needing the
forage we have also tried rolling down
and then coming back about a week later
planting and then coming back about a
week later and rolling it down there are
a lot of different techniques of doing
this the bottom line is we can do it we
can roll this ride down let it die it
makes a mat in the middle of the rows it
covers up where the weeds would come the
soybeans come up throw it and the
soybeans yield well as long as there's
sufficient moisture maybe several really
interesting and valuable observations
with this practice and one was that
we've had terrible problems with deer
we've got some fields where we almost
were can't grow soybeans because of the
deer damage Oh
what we found was deer hate eating their
eyes poked by rye heads and when we
crimp the ride down its sometimes it
stays down but usually there's that
annoying habit of bouncing back up a
little bit we do sometimes recreating
bounce back is not that hard to look at
when you realize that when the deer go
out there to eat your soybeans and they
get their eyes poked it discourages them
and we've seen a huge reduction in
damage from the deer just because we
have the right out there it really seems
to frustrate our predators this is a
documented fact and there are some
fields that we had pretty much given up
on growing soybeans on but by doing this
particular practice on those fields like
this this one which is all surrounded by
woods and it's kind of down in the
hollow and grown soybeans would have
been impossible before we tried doing
this we are actually getting some pretty
good Soviets the other benefit is you
can have these really heavy rains that
climate change is bringing us that
damage the soil tremendously and walk
across those fields and not get your
boots dirty the next day you know that
is HUGE also you look at the water
that's pouring out of the fields and
it's clean
instead of muddy you know just think of
the environmental benefits to that but
waiting until fall and fall after
soybeans is when I really cringe at the
soil loss and at the soil structure
damaged we've got this nice thatch of
right that's still there still
protecting it and we have found that
it's very effective to no-till either
rye or triticale and what we've started
no-tilling as triticale and winter peas
into that mulch and we're getting the
protection again notice the protection
the protection that I noticed of the Rye
when we're doing no-till and we have a
stubble sticking up that's double is
protection to the small grain you know
there are some downsides for instance if
it's tying up nitrogen and those can be
managed we just have to be aware of them
and manage them but I think there's a
tremendous potential for making our
grains winter better and having better
yields just from the protective effect
of keeping wind and heavy rain events or
at least the damage from them at minimum
the good thing is we know where the end
of the rainbow is and this is not I
don't say this lightly we really drew at
the end of the day you know hopefully
there's a financially stable farm an
environmentally stable farm that is able
to adapt to the changing whims of
weather which we can't avoid markets
costs you know things that go wrong and
still have fun we said this at a meeting
of conventional farmers about three
years ago and when I said and still have
fun heads went up all over like what's
that if we cannot be doing this and
having fun why do it we are very
fortunate we feel very blessed that
we've been able to do this with our
family one son working with class one
son working with me and our daughter
just an hour down the road
we feel very fortunate to be surrounded
by a neighborhood of old order
Mennonites who are our friends our
neighbors when we had a fire year and a
half ago of a major farm burned within
hours they were there to help us clean
up and rebuild and they put in weeks
months of free labor to help us rebuild
that's what neighbourhood is we have a
community of people who we work with
that we are friends with that we've been
friends with fort with for a long time
we have a group through cornell called
NYC oh that gets together and was just
together yes day before yesterday not we
didn't get there but up in Geneva and
it's a group of farmers organic farmers
from this area that have been getting
together for nearly 30 years
fun is people and fun is feeling with
what we're doing is worthwhile and is
ethical and we have been really
fortunate we have a lot of our articles
that we've written over the years on
various agronomic topics and and
including a bunch of ones on animal
topics too because through the mill we
have to answer a lot of questions on fun
things like mastitis and yannis disease
and they're posted on our website under
info and we have five minutes left to
take questions
[Music]
I want to throw out one more observation
that's a lot of farmers the next
generation doesn't want to be farmers
and I think the problem no we can say
it's not fun or it's not profitable but
I think the bigger problem is most young
people want to do their own thing all
right a whole lot of young people who
say I my dream is to take over mom and
dad's well or mom and dad's vision or
mom and dad's project everyone wants to
do their own and I think as farms get
bigger we have a tendency to build these
units where there's not room for the
next generation to be their own person
and do their own live their own dream
and I really would like to encourage
anyone to make room for this next
generation to express themselves and try
new things
questions and one strike the more Mason
various various parts of it but doesn't
want to go completely certified organic
now witness work or would it not work
unless you had that's that that
specialized market with those
specialized prices and buyers it it is
dependent on getting prices for your
crops that covers your costs the organic
price was a lot higher than it is now
about five ten years ago it's come down
and it's still profitable it's not as
profitable but it is adequately
profitable unfortunately for many
conventional farmers their crops aren't
even meeting the custard production yes
our cost of production is down when you
take it per bushel or per tonne we have
actually lowered our cost of production
so to answer your question as long as
the the prices being paid exceeds the
cost of production
adequate
to allow a little bit of additional
money then it would probably work but
that's that's a big if in conventional
it's highly management dependent there
were we have really saved on our cost of
production is nitrogen we have a farming
system where all of the nitrogen is
being generated internally and that's a
tremendous savings we're also our cost
of cultivating even with this high
technology is much lower than our cost
of herbicides and technology fees before
would have been so we've we've got some
significant savings we do have some
higher costs but we've been fortunate to
be able to hold our yields so that there
are actually higher than they were when
we farm conventionally and in certain
crops like oats they're substantially
higher than conventional yields other
questions denne control i think the weed
control is maybe not as good over
historically as you give us credit for
but the the big thing I'm seeing is that
the cultural practices set you up for
how many weeds Germany and this is an
area that I think graduate student could
make a tremendous career out of is there
are triggers that make weeds either
going to deep dormancy
or that bring the weed seeds out of
dormancy in large numbers and what we're
finding is with our farming system in
our crop sequence when we plant the
ahead of soybeans we're at a point when
the weeds are in relatively deep
dormancy so that even if we have a as a
moderate seed bank of weeds they're
really not germinating at that point in
the rotation or at least where they're
going to impact that crop one
observation our son made here in the
last several years is when we grow
triticale and winter peas as a winter to
cover and then take it as a forage crop
we have virtually no weeds for a month
afterwards no matter what we're planting
and I've had people look at our dry
beans and saying what have you got here
some kind of organic herbicide and as no
it's just in that particular situation
that cycle in the cropping sequence the
weeds are in such a deep dormancy that
they don't come I don't care if they try
to come afterwards because they won't
make it so I think I think in your
question there is the potential for a
really interesting project other
question yes so first of all thanks for
coming it's so important that we get and
for those of you we don't know awesomer
knows that well they really are
celebrities and he in the organic
agriculture world to comment someone on
causes comment about the technology to
guess at all that but we are in the
process of hiring a person what we call
digital agronomy you are more than
welcome to participate in that process
we didn't link you in the seminars every
important person we can link you in
thank you our next project is actually
to dig in more than a mile a fiber-optic
cable because Verizon will not give us
decent service they claim they're giving
us excellent service but the truth is
somewhere else you're mostly in organic
Saint Andres so you've exported a lot of
your carbon the news
anyway right so I know you're growing
your 9 inch in you're growing a lot of
your own carbon how do you deal with
kind of replenishing those well we
aren't mostly a grain operation we grow
a lot of grain and forages but we also
work with three adjacent dairy farms
where they board their heifers and their
dry cows we get all of their manure back
we provide them with all their forages
all their straw there's a great deal of
cycling of nutrients of materials of
cows of Labor of money we have tried to
use our farm and expand the land base
for three young farms in our area who
don't have large land base it gives
classes his cow fix everyday which is
really important for mental health but
it also means that we are we are getting
a lot of manure back we are keeping a
lot of the nutrients in a closed-loop
that may leave our farm physically for a
few months but come back to our farm
actually there in isn't in production
increase from our land base because that
dare that milk and that meat that is
coming from those dairy farms is mostly
being produced by the products of our
cover crops so that we're double
cropping almost the entire farm in one
way or other so that when we harvest our
winter wheat or we harvest our spelt the
neck then we also get the straw which
these farmers can have for free as long
as I get it back when it's dirty and
we're also harvesting the cover crop
afterwards which is very high quality
forage and I would contend that nobody
under even the most efficient conditions
could grow monoculture alfalfa as
cheaply as we can produce that forage as
a cover crop because we're dividing the
cost of that land by two crops for us it
makes a lot of sense and we've talked a
lot of people about this model and we're
actually thinking about putting together
a grant
to kind of codify it and describe it and
turn it into more of a template it works
really well in in neighborhoods where
there are both small dairy farms and
also grain farms because it does there
are so many synergies that transcend the
the individual parts the sum is so much
greater and it it's also a great way to
help young farmers get started in kind
of a sheltered environment where that
these farms know that they've got the
top quality forage the top quality grain
and lots of straw so the the risks of
starting at a dairy farm are a whole lot
less it's it's it's a pretty nice system
and it's something that I think more and
more farms could see this as a way of
being a community resource rather than
each individual farm is being on island
to itself there's several ways this
strengthens ODE biology of our farm one
is that we're able to grow BMR sorghum
Sudan during the summer when there are
periods when the soil otherwise might
only have weeds or some or a less
productive cover crop and by having all
this diversity we're taking advantage of
the differences between c3 crops and c4
crops
we're able to grow crops that will start
growing at 40 degrees Fahrenheit or even
colder during the cool fall and spring
months and then switching to c4 crops
that can tolerate high temperatures and
make much more efficient water use
during midsummer so I believe we're
actually catch capturing a lot more
carbon out of the atmosphere and
producing a lot more food just by having
the farm have a large amount of the
optimally adapted species for the time
of year through more of the year unless
you think of us as grain farmers at any
given time we do have 75 to 80 cows on
our farm so that really does kind of
define us to anything else
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu